nous sommes contre la guerre mais
d'abord nous vous demandons de rendre
hommage à la mémoire des victimes par
une minute de silence
c'est devenu un rituel à chaque
représentation la troupe affiche son
soutien à l'ukraine
avant de faire retentir l'hymne
ukrainien
puis le rideau se lève et le temps d'un
ballet russe la guerre semble presque
loin sur scène danseurs russes
ukrainiens ou encore moldave se côtoient
pour raconter l'histoire de la belle au
bois dormant et pour ce danseur
ukrainien même pendant les répétitions
difficile de se concentrer sur les parts
dans le district no nestea kuaté
secousse tennistique important pour moi
de continuer à avancer pour porter un
message est en soit et même si c'est
parfois très compliqué d'appliquer se
faire dépister que le déconcentre
souvent
je pense sans cesse à ma famille à ce
qui se passe chez - les chats est
horrible
sa compagne russe elle interprète le
rôle de la belle au bois dormant elle
n'a pas hésité une seconde à le soutenir
[Musique]
si nice n'a pour l'instant je ne sais
pas si je rentrerai en russie je suis
russe mais mon mari et ukrainiens les
siens et j'aime le craignent lorsque
l'on danse c'est une bouffée d'oxygène
nous sommes très unis et nous devons
nous soutenir nous voulons la paix
tajani en france plusieurs
représentations russes ont été
déprogrammés la productrice salue le
courage et la solidarité de sa troupe
passe chacun de nous a de la famille ou
des amis en ukraine et en russie
[Applaudissements]
sam pétersbourg oui nous appelons
saint-péterbourg notre allié russe mais
on s'y tient surtout pas poutine on
soutient tchaïkovski et on soutient la
culture et en marquant leur soutien à
l'ukraine les danseurs russes ignore
comment ils seront accueillis à leur
retour pour l'instant leur seule arme
c'est la danse
[Musique]